did you see trump last night on fox news
no oh he went hard in the paint he did
oh my god he went you forget like i know
he's crazy but you forget how much of a
better talker he is than biden like oh
my god oh yeah he released the hounds he
did oh my god i'm biting he's like this
this is the worst tragedy in in american
history you know we're strategic
american history where we did in
afghanistan these porn is you know he's
just sticking it to him did you and then
they go whoa biting us listen he didn't
know what's going on he's not he's like
he goes who knows who's making the calls
he's not he's not doing it
did you see that tick tock or whatever
it was where they come here hey brian no
my nephew was showing hey
my nephew showed it to me my nephew no
more tick tock the difference between
biden i mean and no i'm sorry obama and
trump when they talk about the same
thing where binds like he he was uh
osama bin laden was uh given a burial at
sea and and just cut obama he died like
a dog yeah i died like a dog that's
trump's problem
he's like he's so hard oh [ __ ] it's so
funny you know the name of the tick
tocker i i can find it we were laughing
so hard the guy was laughing oh we're
pulling up the tick tock if i can find
it i i typed in the biden and trump
thing didn't work
[Music]
brian you're more educated than me i saw
that
obama when he was in office he let go
the head of the taliban is that true or
is that just yeah he didn't traded him
he trained
bernthal
so do you think if he never did that
well the guy spent from 2002 to 2014 in
guantanamo bay i mean and hadn't been
actually accused of a crime he was just
considered close to osama bin laden so
he was too dangerous to let go and as a
result you know yeah
so that's gonna be a problem dude
now the taliban what they do is they
they create a like uh a shield for the
terrorist of flourish yeah so it's not
gonna be a problem like now but a few
years ago yeah yeah or that's the big or
though or the taliban realizes that
there's not a whole lot of profit in
that kind of behavior and it might make
sense oh you're adding more money to
come into the fold a little bit no
that's not a chance well it's like they
were saying like they were interviewing
one guy from taliban and you know cnn's
around where they're like actually
taliban's opening given women rights
yeah and then they showed them a woman
with refused to wear the turban and was
talking about women rights oh they shot
her in the face oh [ __ ] so they're
erasing all pictures of women in there
in uh afghanistan now too
uh did we show the clip of the lady
talking about the taliban we did that
yeah where she was like they're shouting
death americans but they actually seem
pretty cool yeah she's on the street
you're like oh
yeah it's just it's like a white
reporter like from the americans yeah
she's in the whole at the end of the day
she's like they're shouting death the
americans but they seem pretty cool the
worry is that the country falls into
civil war yeah and and and again and uh
because you said
there's tribes it's it's tribal i talked
to some guys who are over there and like
are knee-deep in that [ __ ] and i said uh
because we were doing the king thing
yesterday we're talking about i wanted
to get a little facts on it because you
know we don't nobody here knows what the
[ __ ] going on
and they said it was it's it's a good
idea to get out of there but not the way
we did it yes they said the way we did
it was not the best the
big lesson though is this with all our
intel you know all our intel and all all
the all the policy people who study this
what what i think is very significant is
that none of them none of them saw the
country following they were all quickly
yeah and we're talking about our experts
who they were all are basically calling
the shots like bindings just like that
it was fell in 11 days and no one saw
that we thought and four days 60 percent
of the country was taken over four days
what does that mean what that means is
that the taliban as we call them have
enormous amount of sympathy among the
people in that country because a lot of
the a lot of the effort wasn't reaching
a lot of those people
so
you have to take that into account right
yeah it's a little bit like the way the
viet cong in vietnam had so much
sympathy then people weren't didn't have
allegiance to saigon
and it was like well that you have to
look at what's really going on in the
hearts and minds of the people and
that's hard but they they had a retired
four-star general on the other day
and
and he was just talking about he's like
like the taliban and the people in
afghanistan they don't want americans
there like so we have so much power with
that
we before we just dipped out and [ __ ]
like there's like they think they don't
know the reports they think there's
between 10 to 30 000 americans stuck
over there now so he's like
it would have been so much easier to go
all right we'll leave you have our word
but we have to get all these people out
as soon as they're out then we'll leave
yeah cause they want us out so bad
they've been like all right cool fly
everybody out that's fine and we could
have got everybody out but instead of
doing this knee-jerk reaction like all
right we're out people are [ __ ] dude
yes [ __ ] now i did hear that and those
are experts that were in biden's air
given they had no idea and had no idea
you know but a lot but the guys who are
the military they have ideas
yeah but they're not they can't they
don't have the presence there
afghanistan has always been that
whirlpool you get sucked into you try to
go in there with a light footprint as we
said and you still get sucked yeah it
goes
even the some with the russians tried to
take it over what years ago
the 80s 70s genghis khan alexander yeah
great who else uh the russians nobody
nobody conquers afghanistan i've got the
british now remember those and those
taliban they're only like thirty five
thousand strong
seventy five thousand about they they
don't they don't know the exact number
they're so
roughly that 75
75 000 took over the country and there's
300 000 and an air force plus an air
force we took the air force and their
drones away so that's a little tough but
they did have 75 000 over 300 thousand
that's how good of fighters
also the country itself the towns the
military massive desertions they were
just like i'm not fighting those guys
i'm not killing those guys i know those
guys i know those guys i don't know you
america yeah yeah i know yes but simon
that a we know them and b they're better
fighters than us and see we really don't
know what the [ __ ] we're doing so we're
gonna die what is that expression it's
one thing to know what you're fighting
against we went in there and i i agreed
with why we went in there because they
were harboring our enemies al qaeda and
i i supported that 100 percent that
that's what we were fighting against
terrorism and we beat the problem is yes
we beat it the problem is you have to
ask yourself if you're there for 20
years what are you fighting for and when
you don't know what you're fighting for
that's very you're saying if you're if
in afghan if you're in germany if you're
american well if you're an american
you're fighting so that doesn't come
back
that right that's right but it seems to
me that we did that after we bombed tora
bora and they already went into
waziristan pakistan and so
you know we turned our our
we had all that military machinery and
who was there the taliban who'd never
killed americans we turn on them and
then we got ourselves whether we knew it
or not into a type of civil we we took
sides even though we tried to use the
northern alliance to do it blah blah
blah this is dicey man it's dicey it's
what vitamin b remembered for for sure
it's what he would be remembered for i
don't fault him before pulling out
ultimately i faulted him for the way he
pulled out that's what always everybody
always says i just think it's very
significant that no one saw it falling
that quickly and that's why none of us
knew what was really going on in the
hearts and minds of average afghanis